Les trucs qui sortent des oreilles
c'est ça, c'est le souffle divin
faut essayer de se mettre dans l'bain
parce que sinon vous n'allez pas comprendre
L’or est
pour nous le matériau le plus précieux.
Inoxydable et doré comme le soleil, il a
servi dans de nombreuses sociétés pour fabriquer
les objets de grand prestige.
Vous l’avez déjà vu sur cette chaîne,
en Grèce à l’époque mycénienne, ce sont
des feuilles d’or qui prennent les traits
des rois.
Au Mexique de l’époque classique toutefois,
le matériau le plus précieux n’est pas
un métal doré mais une pierre verte, le
jade.
Souvent d’un vert profond comme la jungle
qui avait englouti les sites mayas, les masques
et bijoux de jade sont devenus les emblèmes
de cette civilisation mystérieuse.
Représentations iconiques, à la fois réalistes
et hautement symboliques, elles disent beaucoup
de la pensée des anciens Mayas.
Aujourd’hui, on va donc analyser cette pierre
hors du commun, le jade chez les Mayas.
En guise de préliminaire, il faut d’abord
se pencher sur la matière première.
Les géologues distinguent en réalité plusieurs
types de jade : la jadéite et la néphrite.
Ces deux termes dérivent pourtant de la même
origine, d’une observation qu’on fait
au XVIe siècle, les Espagnols en débarquant
au Nouveau Monde.
Les conquérants mentionnent en effet que
les indigènes utilisent de la pierre verte
comme amulette, en particulier pour se prémunir
des calculs rénaux.
Le rein se dit « nephro » en grec, et les
pierres vertes se voient rapidement qualifiées
de néphrites, les pierres du rein.
Le mot jade, vient lui du terme ijada en espagnol,
ce qui signifie le flanc
(flanc avec un « c », sinon ça fait pas pareil).
Là encore parce que les indigènes portaient
des pierres vertes sur le côté du corps.
Avec ces deux noms, néphrite et jadéite
les géologues distinguent deux types de pierre verte.
La première, la néphrite est de la famille
des amphiboles, c’est un silicate de calcium
et de magnésium.
C’est ce jade qui est utilisé dès l’Antiquité
en Chine, mais il est en fait absent d’Amérique.
Les Mayas utilisaient eux le deuxième type,
la jadéite.
C’est une roche de la famille des pyroxènes,
composée de sodium et d’aluminium (je vous
mets même la formule pour les connaisseurs
NaAlSi2O6).
Je peux faire des vidéos de géologie (nan quand-même...)
Je vous conseille une belle chaîne de géologie, Science de comptoir
C'est excellent, c'est très drôle
Elle est bien connue des préhistoriens européens
parce qu’au Néolithique, les jadéites
étaient aussi prisées pour fabriquer des
haches.
Celles provenant des gisements alpins ont
même été échangées à l’échelle de
tout le continent, on en retrouve en Bretagne,
en Ecosse, au Danemark…
Bref.
Le jade, c’est une roche dure, elle se situe
aux alentours de 6-7 sur l’échelle de Mohs.
C’est une roche métamorphique, c’est-à-dire
qu’elle se forme en profondeur, au niveau
de la rencontre de plaques tectoniques, à
de hautes pressions et des températures de
300 à 400°C.
Les gisements de jade utilisés par les Mayas
sont donc situés le long de la faille de
Motagua au Guatemala, à la jonction entre
la plaque tectonique nord-américaine et caraïbe.
Ces gisements sont exploités pendant plusieurs
millénaires et sont au cœur d’un grand
commerce à l’échelle de l’Amérique
centrale.
En réalité le jade peut prendre un grand
nombre de teintes, du blanc au noir, en passant
par le rose ou le bleu, mais celles qui ont
exercé le plus d’attrait sont ses nuances
de vert.
Ce sont les inclusions de différents minéraux
additionnels qui font varier sa couleur.
Mais sans la possibilité de réaliser des
analyses chimiques, les Mayas ne distinguaient
les différentes pierres que par leurs aspects,
leurs origines et leurs qualités artisanales.
D’autres pierres vertes ont d’ailleurs
été utilisées au Mexique ancien, comme
l’amazonite, la serpentine, la malachite
et la turquoise.
Certaines obsidiennes, du verre volcanique,
peuvent aussi présenter des reflets verts,
c’est le cas de celle de Teotihuacan qui
commerçait avec les Mayas.
Moins dures et prestigieuses, ces pierres
partageaient tout de même, grâce à leurs
nuances de vert, certaines qualités du jade.
Vous l’avez compris, le point le plus important
pour eux, c’est que ce soit vert.
C’est cette couleur qui véhicule une symbolique
importante, on y reviendra.
Le jade est travaillé depuis une époque
ancienne.
La civilisation-mère de la Mésoamérique,
les Olmèques, installés au bord du Golfe
du Mexique au IIe millénaire avant J.-C.,
sont les premiers à produire des objets en jade.
Ils produisent notamment des haches, toutefois
plus sophistiquées et décorées que celles
du Néolithique européen.
Le travail du jade, roche dure et précieuse,
est confié à des artisans spécialisés.
Et on a la chance d’avoir pu fouiller et
documenter précisément plusieurs ateliers
du monde maya.
Le plus important est celui de Cancuén, situé
à 120 kilomètres au nord des gisements,
qui a fonctionné entre le VIIe et le Xe siècle
de notre ère.
A Cancuén, ce ne sont pas seulement des éclats
de jade et des déchets de taille qui ont
été découverts, mais aussi une grande partie
des outils employés par les artisans.
Percuteurs en pierre dure, polissoirs, mais
aussi, plus étonnant, des forets rotatifs
et des scies à corde pour découper les blocs.
Le sciage à la corde est une technique très
ancienne, d’ailleurs aussi attestée au
Néolithique en Europe.
Grâce au simple mouvement d’une corde en
matière végétale montée sur un archet,
les artisans s’attaquaient aux pierres les
plus dures.
La cordelette entraîne avec elle de la matière
abrasive qu’on a ajouté, généralement
il s’agit de sable de quartz, d’obsidienne
ou même de jade, le tout arrosé d’eau.
Avec de l’adresse, de la force et surtout
beaucoup de patience, les artisans pouvaient
découper précisément les blocs de jade
pour obtenir des plaquettes de la forme souhaitée.
L’abrasif pouvait aussi éventuellement
être utilisé avec des couteaux de silex
ou d’obsidienne directement sur la pierre.
Dans tous les cas, je vous raconte pas les
tendinites.
On part dans la technique là...
Vous vous plaignez tout le temps que c'est pas assez long donc
je m’exécute
Si vous vous voulez du plus long archéo c'est forcément plus technique
Le polissage se faisait sur des pierres tendres,
puis avec des roseaux qui sont des végétaux
riches en silice, et enfin l’objet est lustré
avec une peau.
Comme souvent, simplement avec du bois, des
cordes, de l’ingéniosité et du temps,
les artisans des temps anciens faisaient des
merveilles.
Le travail du jade était donc un artisanat
bien rodé et très spécialisé chez les
Mayas.
Cette pierre verte extraordinaire était utilisée
pour fabriquer divers objets de prestige,
pendentifs, ornements d’oreille, etc., mais
les plus fascinants sont bien entendu les
masques mortuaires.
Une quinzaine de masques ont été découverts
à ce jour dans le monde maya dans plusieurs
grands sites tels que Palenque, Calakmul ou
Tikal pour les plus connus.
Ils étaient déposés dans les sépultures
des souverains des cités-états, soit directement
sur le visage, soit à côté.
Fabriqués à l’aide de tesselles de jade
collées à la résine sur une âme de bois,
ils ont été retrouvés à l’état de fragment
car les matières organiques se sont désagrégées.
Les archéologues ont donc remonté patiemment
les tesselles de jade pour reconstituer les
visages au plus près de l’original.
Malheureusement il existe peu de photos des
masques au moment de leur trouvaille et les
principales publications mexicaines qui documentent
le travail de reconstitution sont indisponibles
en France ou sur internet.
Il y a toutefois quelques exemples pour lesquels
ces informations sont accessibles.
L'autre chose qui va être compliquée pour cette vidéo
c'est qu'il existe très peu de photos
elles sont d'une qualité déplorable
donc vous allez voir souvent la même illustration pour telle tombe tel masque
je suis dégoutée parce que je suis allée visiter tous ces sites en 2015
On m'a volé mon appareil photo...
Le plus emblématique, et qui trône en majesté
dans un pavillon spécial du Musée d’Anthropologie
Nationale à Mexico (entre nous le plus beau
musée du monde), est le masque de Pakal,
le souverain de la cité de Palenque (entre
nous le plus beau site archéo du monde) au
VIIe siècle de notre ère.
La dernière restauration de ce masque a été
réalisée entre 2001 et 2003, pour tenter
d’approcher davantage des traits de son
illustre modèle.
Les archéologues ont pu s’aider de deux
sculptures en stuc et en argile qui représentaient
le souverain, déposées dans sa tombe.
Sur ce masque, les artisans ont utilisé six
teintes différentes de jade, employées dans
des parties distinctes du visage pour souligner
les éléments importants.
Les teintes plus vives dites « jade impérial
» sont employées au centre du visage pour
attirer le regard.
Cette variété rare de jade était la plus
prisée aux temps anciens, comme aujourd’hui
d’ailleurs.
Le vert profond provient de sa composition
chimique originale, ici ce sont des minéraux
de chrome qui remplacent l’aluminium.
Le remontage du masque a permis de mettre
en évidence que le roi de Palenque avait
subi dans son enfance une déformation céphalique.
C’est une pratique répandue dans l’aristocratie
maya, qui la pratiquait sur le crâne encore
malléable des nourrissons à l’aide de
planchettes attachées à l’arrière de
la tête.
Cette déformation artificielle était faite
pour donner à la tête une forme oblongue,
ressemblant à un épi de maïs.
Les cheveux du roi redressés sur la tête
ressemblent alors aux soies de l’épi.
C’est étrange, mais on verra que c’est
un symbole récurrent.
Sauf que cette coutume, à part vous faire
ressembler à Abraham Simpson, a en plus pour
conséquence un développement asymétrique
du visage et des cavités oculaires.
Concrètement, ça veut dire une joue plus
grosse que l’autre et un méchant strabisme.
On ne juge pas.
Là où ça devient intéressant, c’est
que cette asymétrie se retrouve aussi sur
les masques de jade.
C’est le cas pour celui de Pakal, qui a
le côté droit plus protubérant que le gauche.
Mais l’exemple le plus frappant est celui
du masque de Rovirosa où le strabisme divergent
du personnage apparaît clairement.
Pour le masque de Calakmul, dont les 97 tesselles
de jade ont été remontées avec précision,
cela montre encore une fois une déformation
frontale oblique avec des conséquences sur
les arcades et les pommettes.
L’asymétrie est visible, le côté droit
est plus proéminent que le gauche.
A Oxkintok, l’une des plus anciennes cités
du nord du Yucatan, un masque de jade a aussi
été retrouvé dans une tombe princière.
Il est composé de tesselles très fines,
presque translucides par endroits.
Là encore l’asymétrie est visible, le
côté droit est proéminent et le côté
gauche est plat.
La déformation du crâne, visible sur les
masques associe donc clairement le souverain
au dieu Maïs, et fait de lui un nourricier
pour son peuple.
Mais au-delà de ça, ce sont tous les éléments
en jade qui participent de cette symbolique.
Pierre verte dont les teintes les plus prisées
sont celles des feuilles de maïs, le jade
est associé dès les périodes anciennes
à cette plante indispensable au Mexique.
On l’a vu, le jade est déjà utilisé par
les Olmèques au Ier millénaire avant notre
ère pour produire des haches décorées.
Ce sont en réalité déjà des images du
dieu Maïs, et elles témoignent de l’association
ancienne entre la pierre verte et la fertilité.
Les Mayas de l’époque classique entre 250
et 900 après J.-C. ont donc hérité de cette
signification.
On le voit encore une fois dans la tombe de
Pakal.
En plus de son masque mortuaire, le souverain
était doté de colliers et bracelets en perles
de jade, de bagues, de grandes perles déposées
dans ses mains et sur ses pieds, et une statuette
du dieu Maïs crocodile au niveau du bassin.
Le symbolisme est présent dans tous les éléments.
Les bracelets de Pakal sont composés de 8
rangs de 25 perles, 8 étant le chiffre associé
au dieu Maïs.
La forme ronde des perles et leur polissage
minutieux rappelle aussi les grains de maïs
à maturité.
La pierre verte est par ailleurs réputée
exhaler le souffle divin, elle est censée
produire de la vapeur, l’humidité qui rend
fertile.
Elle est en quelque sorte une manifestation
physique du souffle vital.
En somme, le souverain, comme le grain de
maïs semé, est enseveli et attend sa résurrection
grâce aux eaux du monde souterrain.
Les boucles d’oreille proéminentes évoquent
elles aussi le vent et les pluies, la fertilité.
Dans une tombe plus ancienne du même site[4],
un masque de jade prend cette fois-ci les
traits d’un jaguar, et est surmonté d’une
coiffe d’oiseau.
Le visage est encerclé par une rangée de
tesselles de coquillage.
Le dignitaire défunt est ici complètement
assimilé à des figures mythologiques, le
jaguar et les coquillages renvoyant tous les
deux au monde souterrain, celui qu’il faut
traverser pour renaître.
Ici aussi, le souverain attend sa résurrection
en tant que dieu Maïs.
Le jade joue donc un rôle religieux primordial.
Symbole de vie et de fertilité, il est décrit
dans la mythologie maya comme l’un des éléments
originels du monde.
Mais s’il a été exploité pour ses qualités
mystiques, il a aussi eu des usages plus profanes.
Traditionnellement, la circulation du jade
chez les Mayas se faisait entre personnages
de la noblesse, elle constituait souvent la
dot des femmes à marier.
On trouve ainsi des bijoux de jade à Copan
au Honduras, inscrits du nom d’aristocrates
de Palenque à plus de 400 kilomètres au
nord-ouest, ce qui témoigne sans doute d’un
mariage à longue distance.
Ces bijoux et éléments de parures prestigieux
ne pouvaient être possédées que par une élite.
Ces échanges sont donc plus des cadeaux que
des transactions monétaires, ils prennent
place dans une relation interpersonnelle,
entre gens de la haute, et ne peuvent pas
régler des dépenses du quotidien avec des
inconnus.
Mais aujourd’hui, certains pensent que le
jade a pu jouer dans certains cas le rôle
d’une monnaie.
Dans leur article de 2018 intitulé « Fifty
Shades of Green… »
Brigitte
Kovacevich et Michael Callaghan, estiment
que les perles de jade auraient pu être utilisées
pour régler des transactions commerciales.
Petites, faciles à transporter, elles ont
pu servir de monnaie d’échange.
Enfilées en collier, elles deviennent l’équivalent
d’une bourse pour les pièces de monnaie.
En Afrique et dans l’océan Indien, l’utilisation
de perles de coquillage en guise de monnaie
est par ailleurs attestée largement, alors
pourquoi pas le jade ?
La plus grande production de perles de jade
à la fin de la Période classique, notamment
par l’atelier de Cancuén dont on a déjà
parlé, semble indiquer un glissement vers
l’utilisation monétaire.
Les perles de meilleure qualité restent trouvées
dans les tombes de l’aristocratie, mais
les perles plus banales sont réparties de
manière assez homogène dans les sites tardifs.
Les haches en jadéite auraient aussi pu jouer
le même rôle.
De forme assez régulière, elles s’apparentent
à des lingots et auraient pu régler des
transactions plus conséquentes, en complément
des perles.
Une théorie novatrice qu’il faudra soumettre
aux futures découvertes.
En résumé, qu’ils soient symboles de renouveau
et de fertilité, supports des expressions
artistiques les plus abouties ou simples monnaies
d’échange, les objets de jade restent un
témoignage particulièrement précieux pour
la connaissance du monde maya.
Au cœur de la mythologie et des croyances
dans l’au-delà, cette pierre a fasciné
les anciens Mayas et continue de passionner
les visiteurs des musées archéologiques.
On est pas si différents des Mayas hein…
Après, faut avoir envie de se réincarner
en épi de maïs,
mais bon ça c’est encore autre
chose...
Je vous remercie d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
Vous pouvez la partager, la commenter et aussi soutenir la chaîne
via les plateformes uTip et Tipeee
Je vous remercie et vous dis à la prochaine, salut !